you tastes I mean what I've heard of him
is not good he's part of human
trafficking or something like that what
people keep saying that he does human
trafficking but he hasn't been charged
with anything at all because he lets the
country know so the allegation was in
Romania but there's no evidence at all
some people keep saying these things but
he hasn't been charged with anything
yeah but like even what he says in his
video I've watched a little on Tick Tock
as a feminist I don't appreciate how he
talks about women they know that he
treats women badly he talks about it can
you give an example because I haven't
seen him say anything bad or mean
towards women really because I've met
him personally and I've never
experienced anything negative and all
you guys are have seen is through tiktok
yeah okay but if you met him for a few
minutes well what are you talking about
man no I know we're friends he's a
friend he's a good friend I've met him
plenty of time do you not think there's
a problem with judging people from what
you see on the internet things have been
taken out of context
just a lot of content about him that was
negative so but like